les matins à jeter des centaines de
dollars
ja
la boulangère les souris il ne la
regardait par terre
et pourtant
elle est très belle
les clients
ne voyait qu'elle
il nous faut bénir qu'elle était
vraiment très croustillant au temps de
ses croissants
pmv
mélancolique le soir dans son côté à ce
jeune homme distant
et il est payante voilà tout
elle ne savait pas tiré
là
ils
jouent le jeu
des pâquis
voyez
ne savait
lui envoyait tan aveugle être offert son
bonheur
et la fille qui monte barrett
acheter des lunettes à l'élu de son
coeur
ou deux jours de
travail
dans la boulangerie en fait un soir on
et marées
bouton blanc qu'elle était belle
m
et deux
réunion en et destin de tes gosses n'ont
peut-être pas tant
gambadant parmi les brioches se
remplissant les pages de petits pains au
chocolat
bon bah après la chanson du boulanger il
va falloir qu'on passe à la chanson du
berger michel berger qui a fait la
chanson pour france gall voici musique